voilà maintenant ça on appelle ça les
relous maintenant tout le monde va les
appeler les rôles ou à l'eau bien sûr et
géraldine ya une différence quand tu
parles avec quelqu'un et puis un échange
ou alors quand tu te balades dans la rue
tu ne demande rien à personne et a deux
possibilités soit tu baisse les yeux
parce que si tu croises le regard il va
y avoir une phrase ou quoi soit tu le
regardes est bon il va quand même y
avoir une phrase on est hyper
progressiste alors en 2021
enfin progressons sur ce sujet et bravo
pour votre initiative parce que moi j'ai
plus envie qu'on me dise mademoiselle t
charmante ça me saoule c'est pas un
compliment c'est pas un compliment moi
quand je marche dans la rue dont c'est
pas de toute façon quand il ya une
personne soit elle ce elles se sont
hyper forte moissonner charmante c'est
bien bernard quand tu me dis je suis
charmante c'est différent tu vois rien
qui doit rue du trône et 8 heures on
fait ça je ne connais ambages et ont
envie qu'ils fassent une appréciation
sur mon physique d'autant plus en été
quand même être un mini short alors là
ça fuse non on n'a pas on à paris et
quand ils sont en groupe c'est encore
pire
donc au bout d'un moment avançons sur
les sujets que la justice soutiennent
tout ça madame la ministre
justement à la pause et jean-michel
est-ce que est ce que vous voyez à une
une coïncidence entre les quartiers
séparatistes et les autres sans relou
est-ce qu'on peut il ya une super
position possible
est ce qu'il ya une forme de séparatisme
dans ces quartiers sans relou est ce que
est ce que les gens qui agissent comme
ça sont plus fréquemment présent dans
les quartiers séparatistes parce que en
fait si vous faites pas cet exercice là
pardonnez moi mais c'est la poésie la
tartiflette quoi je vais vous dire les
classes politiques la tartiflette
c'est à dire on n'y voit rien sa dalle
peu de danger on n'y voit rien et donc
du coup la panique et pas efficace
accord merci oui allez-y juste deux
exemples basé sur mon expérience
personnelle parce que hélas on a tout
des histoires comme ça qui nous sont
restés en mémoire moi j'ai grandi dans
une cité sur le bord du périphérique et
avec ma soeur très clairement on devait
fomenter des stratégies d'évitement
avant de sortir ont regardé par la
fenêtre ou disait bail à la bande qui
est là là il ya un type qui est là donc
là on fait comme si on n'entendait pas
là en avant c'était jamais vous proférez
c'était la vie en cité mais je vous
raconte c'est une autre chose qui mérite
j'étais pour la mère de famille j'étais
trentenaire j'étais suivie dans un train
par un type qui était bien sous tous
rapports à la gare montparnasse qui
étaient en costume-cravate avec une
petite mallette et un gobelet starbucks
j'ai eu la peur de ma vie je m'en suis
sortie je sais pas comment mais qui
macule façon très agressive et donc je
crois qu'avoir un costard et habiter
dans le xvième c'est pas ça garantit pas
que d'accord et j'ai plein de cadeaux
j'ai plein d'exemples comme celui qui a
débloqué marlène schiappa je vous le dis
par des mecs en costume avec vous le dit
question